Kentucky is just one of ten states where
rivers are rising after a week of
relentless rain in the South in the
North 34 preparing for a bitter blast of
sub-zero temperatures today and tomorrow
chief weather caster Lonnie Quinn of our
New York station wcbs-tv here is here
Lonnie how cold is it gonna get oh it's
gonna get down into the the negative
numbers take a look at this where we're
starting off this morning I mean my
goodness International Falls it's 25
below that's your actual thermometer
reading wind chills are colder than that
we have set records already today in La
Crosse at 14 below Madison is at 10
below Dubuque is at 13 below in that air
mass is going to make its way to the
Northeast for tomorrow so for Saturday
places like caribou main starting off at
22 below zero Concord New Hampshire 13
degrees below zero New York City
tomorrow about about 15 or 16 degrees
Anthony so that will be the coldest air
we've had in New York City so far this
year then you get down okay to the south
you were talking about the flooding all
of the red dots show you where we have
flooding taking place as of right now
this area is running a surplus of about
a foot of extra rain than they should
have in fact there are portions of
Mississippi right here that have picked
up 12 inches of rain in about a week or
so and the jet stream is responsible for
a lot of certainly it has a lot to do
with those temperatures and if you take
a look at his dip so far to the South
that places like Atlanta and Nashville
Tennessee are experiencing really cold
temperatures out there and that jet
stream is so far south now that it's
just south of the Jets paths that are
flying from say New York to to Heathrow
getting there in record time last
weekend that's a little bit slower right
now because again they're flying just
north of that jet stream that's a the
way we see everything here guys Tony
let's go over to you all right Lonnie
thank you very much